وتعليقا على قرار المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه قال جوزيف بوريل مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان قرار
المحكمه هو البدايه في سلسله المحاسبه
وتحميل المسؤولين الروس المسؤوليه عن
الجرائم والفضاءات التي ارتكبوها في
اوكرانيا على حد تعبيره
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه صرحت ان هناك
ارضيه معقوله للاعتقاد ان بوتين يتحمل
مسؤوليه شخصيه عن هذه الجرائم وشده
الجرائم بنظر المحكمه تتحدث عن نفسها هذا
قرار مهم للعداله الدوليه ولشعب اوكرانيا
اوضحنا دائما ان المسؤولين عن العدوان على
اوكرانيا يجب تقديمهم للعداله وقرار
المحكمه والبدايه في مسلسل المحاسبه
وتحميل المسؤولين الروس المسؤوليه عن
الجرائم والفضاءات التي ارتكبوها في
اوكرانيا الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعم عمل
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وتحقيقها ولن
يكون هناك مجال للافلات من العقاب